This will be a short tutorial
on infinite series, their
definition and their
basic properties.
What is an infinite series?
We're given a sequence of
numbers ai, indexed by i,
where i ranges from
1 to infinity.
So it's an infinite sequence.
And we want to add the terms
of that sequence together.
We denote the resulting sum of
that infinity of terms using
this notation.
But what does that
mean exactly?
What is the formal definition
of an infinite series?
Well, the infinite series is
defined as the limit, as n
goes to infinity, of the finite
series in which we add
only the first n terms
in the series.
However, this definition makes
sense only as long as the
limit exists.
This brings up the question,
when does this limit exist?
The nicest case arises when
all the terms are
non-negative.
If all the terms are
non-negative,
here's what's happening.
We consider the partial sum
of the first n terms.
And then we increase n.
This means that we
add more terms.
So the partial sum keeps
becoming bigger and bigger.
The sequence of partial sums
is a monotonic sequence.
Now monotonic sequences always
converge either to a finite
number or to infinity.
In either case, this
limit will exist.
And therefore, the series
is well defined.
The situation is more
complicated if the terms ai
can have different signs.
In that case, it's possible that
the limit does not exist.
And so the series is
not well defined.
The more interesting and
complicated case is the following.
It's possible that this
limit exists.
However, if we rearrange the
terms in the sequence, we
might get a different limit.
When can we avoid those
complicated situations?
We can avoid them if it turns
out that the sum of the
absolute value of the numbers
sums to a finite number.
Now this series that we have
here is an infinite series in
which we add non-negative
numbers.
And by the fact that we
mentioned earlier, this
infinite series is always
well defined.
And it's going to be either
finite or infinite.
If it turns out to be finite,
then the original series is
guaranteed to be well defined,
to have a finite limit when we
define it that way, and
furthermore, that finite limit
is the same even if we rearrange
the different terms,
if we rearrange the sequence
with which we sum the
different terms.